so I've been following this bee lady on
Instagram so anyways
that bee lady Chris Pratt reveals a
shocking injury it's truly remarkable
and really dangerous but this incident
happened off the set as the actor tells
fans on Instagram he got a little
carried away on a nature walk
so I've been following this bee lady on
the Instagram she's so
cool and brave yeah the actor's a fan of
Erica Thompson the the bin was full of
comb and bees so I got to work removing
the hive the viral beekeepers known for
managing beehives with no protective
gear she goes in front of these hives of
bees and says they're very calm today
I'm going to remove the bee I'm going to
use my bare hands to sift through the
bees and look for the queen so it's
built up this false sense of security in
me
whereas I said I think I can I think I
could control bees too in the caption
Chris even tells her you inspire me but
for real though
so I saw beehive two days ago and I went
towards it and the man standing next to
me said hey careful there's bees and I
said these bees look very calm
and I just stared at these bees and then
one of them come out and that stung me
in the eyeball so anyways
that bee lady yeah and thanks to Real
Housewives of Salt Lake City dramatic
Irish
Colonel Mustard with the rope and black
guy the next morning and the buzz made
its way to Erica who lovingly called out
Chris wait so now you're going to be a
plumber and a beekeeper
foreign
yep a nod to the actor's latest role as
the Nintendo icon in the Super Mario
Brothers movie
and Erica adds if you leave saving the
bees to me and other professionals you
can focus on saving the princess Mario
all right
let's go
oh my God okay yeah looks like Mario
doesn't fare any better than Chris did
but at least the Jurassic world star got
some festive picks before the bee
encounter his wife Catherine
Schwarzenegger shared these intimate
snaps on the gram showing off
thanksgiving's Family Affair I'm at home
with Mamas and babies and and it's just
fantastic man Catherine wrote I am so
grateful and thankful for these memories
and she can be thankful for a holiday
story they'll be telling for years
and I just stared at these bees and then
one of them come out and it stung me in
the eyeball so anyways
that bee lady